avec jean michel faubert avec député la
république en marge de la 8ème
circonscription de seine-et-marne ancien
patron du raid
bonsoir jean michel à fauvergue merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
pour réagir donc à cette conférence de
presse de christophe castaner
aujourd'hui pour vous est ce que le
ministre de l'intérieur a trouvé les
mots justes il a été à la hauteur de la
situation pour calmer les esprits
aujourd'hui oui me semble que le
ministre de l'intérieur a fait les les à
lens un certain nombre d' annonce qu'il
fallait qu'il fallait faire certaines
sont
plus intéressante que l'autre il faut le
reconnaître et et sommes un certain
nombre de députés dans la majorité en
particulier un député dans un groupe de
sécurité de la majorité que je co anime
qui qui avons proposé un certain nombre
de choses et on voit que dans les propos
de christophe castaner ces choses là
sont repris en particulier les propos
qu'il a dit sur l'inspection générale de
la police nationale l'inspection
générale de la gendarmerie nationale
dont on voudrait qu'elle soit en ce qui
nous concerne nous en tout cas qu'elle
soit beaucoup plus autonomes beaucoup
plus indépendantes ou du moins qu'elles
dépendent du du du parlement et qu'elle
de voilà quelques elle il est nécessaire
à un certain moment de marquer la
rupture entre un service enquêteur qui
appartient à la police nationale
actuellement et les enquêtes qu'il fait
donc un peu plus d'indépendance c'est
quelque chose de plutôt pas mal
c'est un voeu pieux ça jean michel
faubert que justement plus
d'indépendance pour le l'igpn on sait à
quel point il est compliqué de réformer
ce type d'administration c'est toujours
très lourd ça vous semble vraiment
réalisable
vous avez raison de le dire c'est
compliqué de transformer les
administrations et surtout au ministère
de l'intérieur ou aux administrations
ont beaucoup beaucoup de poids
énormément de poids aujourd'hui les
annonces café christophe castaner cent
des annonces qui vont dans le bon sens
c'est-à-dire la prise de pouvoir par le
politique qui impose les choses qui est
obligé d'imposer les choses mais qu'il
les aime pitié qui les imposent et ça
c'est quelque chose de nouveau jeu
j'espère y voir quand même une
une dynamique qui ira dans le sens de la
restructuration non pas uniquement pour
le problème qu'on est en train de le
traiter en ce moment mais aussi pour
l'ensemble de la police et la
gendarmerie nationale et pour aller de
manière très très volontaire vers une
police de l'entente du 21e siècle avec
en particulier une police au service des
citoyens qu'on appelle la police de
sécurité du quotidien et que je vous
et qu'on a qu'on a mis en place déjà
depuis deux ans mais dont on voudrait
voir les impacts de plus en plus rapide
parce que c'est cette police là qui sera
au qui doit être au contact de nos
citoyens pour pour pour parler avec eux
pour pour éviter tout type de problème
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
alors christophe castaner veut que
chaque soupçons avérés de racisme je
suis dans la police on traîne une
suspension je veux une tolérance zéro a
dit ministre de l'intérieur le
rassemblement national a réagi
aujourd'hui il estime que le rôle d'un
ministre de l'intérieur c'est
précisément de soutenir la police le
parti accusé emmanuel macron et
christophe castaner de lâcher en clair
la gendarmerie et la police vous
l'ancien policier
qu'en pensez vous côté si vous m'avez
fait venir aujourd'hui c'est parce que
effectivement je suis à la fois ancien
policier hommes politiques
donc je peux avoir une expérience
intéressante dans ce domaine là et je
peux vous dire qu'en tant qu'ancien chef
de la police g g
hu à traiter des affaires de très peu
mais jésus à traiter d'affaires de
policiers qui étaient racistes dans tous
les sens d'ailleurs attendre assis dans
tous les sens qui était qu'ils étaient
des policiers violents qu'ils étaient
des policiers pour certains voleurs etc
mais ce que je veux ce que je veux vous
dire c'est qu'il y en a très peu et qu'à
chaque fois on les a traité avec des
procédures administratives et des
policiers des procédures judiciaires et
que ces procédures là ont abouti à des
sanctions
les sanctions à la fois j administrative
des sanctions pénales
donc on est on est bien bien évidemment
que pour répondre totalement à votre
question les politiques les politiques
et en particulier qui sont aux affaires
sont dans leur rôle en exigent aussi que
l'ap que la police et la gendarmerie et
je partage totalement cette cette idée
là la police et la gendarmerie soient
exemplaires mais ils sont dans leur rôle
aussi quand ils disent que attention on
est dans un état français on n'est pas
dans un état raciste
on n'est pas dans une avec une police
très raciste et on doit aussi respecter
la justice actuellement il ya des vents
mauvais qui voudraient où il ya un
versement d'une inversion des valeurs on
accuse le policier on accuse le
magistrat on accuse les représentants de
l'autorité
c'est quelque chose que l'on doit
rétablir remettre dans le bon sens il y
a je le répète des gens qui sont dans
toutes les professions et dans la baie
la police et la gendarmerie n'y échappe
pas des gens une poignée de gens qui ne
sont pas au niveau de leurs fonctions
cela on doit les on doit on doit les
faire partir de là delà de cette
profession là mais l'ensemble l'ensemble
la police la gendarmerie et la justice
sont au service des citoyens français et
votre reportage le dit bien à bordeaux
où les citoyens bordelais le disent dans
votre reporter jean michel poivert tout
de même effectivement tout le monde
s'accorde à dire voilà il ya des brebis
galeuses
il ya forcément comme dans la société
des policiers racistes comme il ya des
gens racistes dans la société n'est pas
le sentiment parfois que les policiers
deviennent aussi les boucs émissaires
d'une société qui va mal
l'illustration voilà deux du chômage de
la misère économique surtout après cette
crise terrible que nous venons vivre le
travail de police et un travail très
très difficile très dur très délicat
parce que effectivement un certain
moment les policiers se transmute de
sauveur et 2 et 2 et de personnes qui
rendent service et qui assurent la
sécurité de tous vont se transformer
effectivement en particulier sur des
manifestations violentes comme bouc
émissaire de la part de manifestants par
exemple qui sont très dures en a qui
vont s'en prendre à eux parce qu'ils
s'en prennent ils s'en prennent à l'état
et face à eux ils ont des policiers qui
représente l'état selon eux est
effectivement à ce moment là les
policiers passent pour des boucs
émissaires et bien c'est c'est tout ça
qu'il faut faire changer aussi dans les
mentalités
on doit pas pouvoir quand on est
policier on doit pas vivre cet ascenseur
émotionnel qui fait que le lundi on va
être applaudi par toute la population
parce que vous avez sauvé des otages et
parce que la population était en grand
danger et les policiers se sont
sacrifiés et j'en sais quelque chose et
le samedi se faire insulter par des
hordes de manifestants déchaînés
manipulés qui vont qui vont vouloir
casser du flic ou casser du gendarme et
sa selle c'est vraiment pas possible il
faut aussi il faut aussi que la
population française dans son entièreté
fasse aussi sombre son mea culpa là
dessus et réfléchissent à ces situations
là qui met en porte-à-faux l'ensemble
non seulement un policier gendarme mais
l'ensemble des professions d'autorité
merci beaucoup jean-michel fauvergue
réputé la 8e circonscription
seine-et-marne ancien patron du raid
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france